- [Interviewer] So what's your name?
- My name is Sonyah Bison
and my real name is.
I changed my name from a name that I knew
my family would not find
me as my father or whatnot.
I can give you my name
is Lee Bison. Bryson.
I changed my last name and my first name
my middle name, because you know
I don't know. I-
- [Interviewer] What is your name now?
Sonyah Sayza Bison.
My mother inspired me
to be the person I am
but she also ridiculed
me when she get drunk
call me faggoty and stuff.
But I did everything my mama asked me.
Even though certain
things she asked me to do,
I didn't agree but I
still did them. You know?
Cause I love her and she
always took care of me.
But, man, I ain't got
nobody so that means.
And so I've been suffering on the streets
back and forth, you know, prostituting.
And the best thing I do is give head
and it's not, being on the streets
it's not a replacement
of love I don't have.
My psychologist said, I go
out there so I can get love.
It's not the love that I'm
not getting from my family.
I'm not worried about that
because I don't know none of 'em.
I mean, I don't associated with
my brothers and my sisters.
None of them.
I turned to drugs because
that's I don't have nobody.
The kids that I do
have, the girl only want
wanted to be with me
because I was transgender
and I was going to college back then
I was going to cosmetology school.
I was in uptown.
I was trying to make my life better.
- [Interviewer] In Chicago?
- Yeah, in Chicago
And I was homeless everywhere.
I don't know. I just can't fathom.
I'm looking for love, but I can't find it.
I don't know who to be.
I don't know what I am no more. Sometimes.
Sometimes I think I'm a boy, sometimes
because I got five
children by this one girl
and she's a lesbian and
she's bisexual or whatever.
And she's got kids, you know
our kids and I love her to death
but she didn't want me
to be around the kids.
Just, she just wanted,
my sperm was, you know
- [Interviewer] So tell
me about your childhood.
- Okay.
I went to Johnson elementary school
when it was in Houston, Texas.
- [Interviewer] You didn't
grow up with your parents?
- I had my stepdad and my mother.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- It went pretty well.
Girls used to hunt me and chase me down.
I still can't
trying to figure out why
I kept running from 'em.
(laughing)
I played football.
I went to, then we moved back to Chicago.
My mother finally left
him after the abuse and,
- [Interviewer] What was the abuse?
- My stepfather used to beat my mother.
That's why she spends a
lot of time in the church
- [Interviewer] Oh, really?
- And it saddened me too.
That's when my mother met
this man named Elder Mae
he was a Mormon.
We joined the Mormonite church.
It was, (laughs) and I
ain't know what I was.
My mother was a sanctified,
she went to become a Mormon.
Then we moved to Chicago.
I went to heritage middle school
where in the black
schools, I was held back
for some reason.
I was in fourth grade
for almost two years.
When I went, they
transferred me to this other
it's like an all white school,
you've seen the eighties.
- [Interviewer] How was your
relationship with your stepdad?
- I liked my step-daddy
because he was my step-daddy
but I kind of feared
him because as sexually
I felt that I was protecting
my baby sister and my mother
from the abuse or let it be on
me instead of them, you know
- [Interviewer] What would he do?
- He would put his thing between my legs.
Cause at that time I was like four
or five years old when they
cause I remember every
thing he did to me, you know
he'd make me get into
the bathtub with him.
He-
He'd put his finger in me
You know.
Try to put his finger in
He (cries) but, and then.
I'm good. I got the tissue.
My mama didn't-
I'd try to tell her
and she'd say "What you tryin' tell me?"
And she act like I was stupid.
Like, I couldn't say nothing.
So I didn't ever say nothing.
I went to school every day.
I tried to be the best student.
My other brothers and
sisters didn't go to school.
I went to school everyday
because that's my only escape
and religion was my escape too.
I tried all sorts of religion.
try to prove myself to
everybody but myself
and now I've had all A's
in school when they moved
When my mother moved me
had me move to heritage middle school.
She gave me up to this white
guy named Richard Thompson.
He's my legal guardian.
And, but you know he was
a high school teacher
over the high school I was
getting ready to go to.
- [Interviewer] What age were
you when your stepdad was
molesting you?
- Between 4 and 12 years old
- [Interviewer] That
went on for a long time
Yeah, very long time.
My mo-
my mother,
my mother
I'm trying to save her from being abused.
I figured everything that
happened to me was happening to me
so that it wouldn't happen
to my mother or my sisters.
You know, I would say better it be me.
I can suffer the punishment
because I know what's going on.
And my baby sister,
she's just an arm baby.
I ain't want him to try to mess with her
but since I was already
a fine pick, you know,
he had already put his
ding-ding between my legs,
put me in the back bed, laid
on top of me and you know
and made me get into the bathtub with him.
My mother never knew a lick herself
until the one time he hit me in the head
and I started bleeding all over the place.
He threw a shoe at me
because I didn't want to
do what he wanted to do.
I was laying on the couch.
He wanted me to come get in the bed.
And I told him, I didn't feel like it.
And he hit, he threw the
shoe, "Get your ass up."
And it hit me in the side of the head
shoot the little church shoes
in the seventies (laughs) hurt.
And so he took me to the hospital
That's the only way my mother noticed
that she seen the blood
on the pillow and she wanted
to know what happened.
But I knew my mother knew that
if my daddy wasn't around.
He would have killed her
and him, both of them.
And, but I knew my
daddy could not find out
my real dad, he could never
find out if whenever I see him
because my mama would drink
herself to death anyway,
she was doing it anyway.
And she blamed herself after years later.
But if she could have stopped it
then when I was younger, you know,
she didn't do nothing, you know.
I turned around
I got this guy with a friend of the family
like another guy who was
friend of the family.
He picked me up.
I was going through the forest preserve
I always go to the forest preserve to look
at the deers and stuff in
the suburbs of Chicago.
And he picked me up and he was drinkin
He said "Want a beer?"
I said "Yeah, sure!"
You know, my mother always gave me beer.
And so we was in the truck.
He took me all the way to the corn field
And I said, "Why we over here?"
he started scratching on me, he's gonna,
you know, hurting me, you know.
And he ripped my clothes off.
I had to walk what he did to me.
He tried to make me have sex with him.
And all the time I figured out to get out.
I jumped out the truck and ran
down the highway, butt naked.
I was 12 years old,
then by that time or 13
and the police the sheriffs
took me by my mother house
and it was like, nothing really happened.
You knows, someone's
supposed to went to court
You know, but no one went to court.
So,
what can I do?
The only person I can love is me.
And God loves me.
I don't care what people think, you know.
(Somber music)
I do what I do because I enjoy it.
That's the only pleasure I get
out of seeing if I satisfy a
man at least I made him happy.
That's like giving me a
happiness within myself, you know
a little satisfaction.
- [Interviewer] Do you have
regular customers out here?
You're living on skid row now.
- Yeah. I have customers out here.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Your regular customers?
Yes, sir. Yes I do.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your regular customers.
- Well, he's the one that
wanted me to lick his ass
and you know, cause I
did everything he wanted
and other customers, they
want, you know, head.
Cause I enjoy giving it.
I ain't gonna say, cause
this was another transsexual
calls herself "Superhead"
and she's trying to ruin
a scandalize my name.
And I never did nothing to her real bad.
I haven't even talked to her
- [Interviewer] When you
say lick his ass, you mean?
- Yeah, rim hits, you know, butt hole.
- [Interviewer] Oh (laughs)
- Suck his dick
He never comes, but he'll
come by every hour on the hour
and pick me up to do the same
thing each time, you know?
I don't know.
Yeah. I mean, and then
met a few guys that have
they just want the head and
get it, get it over with
then I knew I could do it
and get it out of the way.
And sometimes I do it
for drugs too, you know.
- [Interviewer] And what is your drug?
- Crystal and Cavy.
- [Interviewer] Cavy is what?
- Crack
- [Interviewer] Crack
- Or cocaine.
I preferably call it
the rich person's high
but not enough dream to
make, fulfill my needs.
See crack motivates me in a sexual way
I'd smoke some crack and
I'd go out in the street
and I can do everything with
superb attention, you know
I could focus on the sexual
acts that I ain't got to worry
about old feelings of
my past or my childhood.
It pushed me.
It separates me from everyone, you know
from every all the people.
I become one person, you know.
I dunno it just makes me
a different individual.
You know
- [Interviewer] How long have
you been using crack and?
- Blow?
I started when I was 19, no, 21.
I graduated.
Once I got out of school, college
and my so-called friend,
her name Patricia.
She graduated me from the crack to
she started me on a cigarette.
And I said, "What is this supposed to do?"
But all the time, she was
baiting me, once we got up the
the pipe thing and they
had bowls back then
that's when I noticed
I started losing weight
and getting skinnier.
And, and then I moved.
I didn't think I was hooked, you know
but then after awhile I spent thousands.
I was like on the South
side, some guys that I knew
I called them brothers,
and they stopped the drug
dealers from selling it to me.
I had to go away out of the
area, but then they get mad
at the guy they would cuss them out.
Like I said, "Why y'all doing that?"
"Well we tired you doing this,
hell, you got to get some sleep"
and I'd be up for weeks,
you know? (sniffs)
And that was right before
my mother passed away.
I was called, I was
Every time I go around my mother
I was getting into fights
with her men company
she'll aggravate a fight
and I didn't hit my mother, you know
I don't care.
Like my uncle, my uncle, Juan,
my mother's brother-in-law
my stepdad's brother.
He even came to me when
I was 14 years old too.
But he had liked him better than my-
By then I was already into
the lifestyle of being gay.
I don't know if I chose it or whatnot
but I have a, I have it-
like I have it figured,
how can I be straight
if I got five children by a lesbian girl?
- [Interviewer] Do you think,
you think what happened
to you when you were 4 to 12
with your stepdad kind of
changed your sexuality?
- Yes, I went to a therapist
when I was younger.
I went to a lot of therapists.
I asked him, "Why am I this way?"
Because I thought it was
wrong for me to be me.
I go to the therapist and they said, well
maybe you will change
by you turning 18 or 19.
And you know, these talking
about doing like tests
like they did the monkeys
back in the eighties
they do the test is for the, like
they give you a shock if you respond good.
And I was willing to try it
because I wanted to be normal.
But as, as my normal was gone, you know
I enjoy doing what I was doing.
I enjoy giving pleasure to guys
and girls, I tried the first
girl I ever did something with
she gave me gonorrhea in my throat.
I was at the age of 13 then.
And I find when I (chuckles) it burned
and this is the girl I didn't even know
she's the one that introduced me to crack.
- [Interviewer] Do you think you're happy?
- I, right now I'm saying I'm
about the happiest right now
than I was several years ago.
I was a wreck.
I was ready to,
let's say become a serial killer.
You know, not to other people
but to myself, you know,
my family, they was absolutely
after my mother passed away,
it, you know, I'm happy that she passed
but I'm not happy because
I know where she said
I know she's resting and
no one's hurting her.
But also, I also know that she can't
make me hurt myself no more.
Every time I either try to hang myself
or take up a bunch of pills.
Cause she would say she
wish I was never born.
And I tried to do it,
anything she wanted (crying)
But, I couldn't please her.
I went to different religions,
and he know you're making better, you know
just to make my mother know that I exist.
I studied, I memorized the
Bible, the Quran and she just,
I'm always faggoty,
always the abomination
or she said, she wish I was never born.
And what can I do?
- [Interviewer] Do you
have brothers and sisters?
- Yeah. They don't pretty
much care for my mother
when she get drunk
- [Interviewer] Do you
talk to your siblings?
- No.
She's not-
My mother became later on,
she did change the life.
It was more Muslim Islamic afterwards
but I didn't associate with her no more.
I didn't associate with
my brothers and sisters
because
all my education, you know
I got it because I
wanted to leave one day,
get escape my family.
Man, and my mother had passed away
and I did not make it to her funeral.
She cussed me out and I did
not make it to her funeral.
She said, she wished I was never born.
And the empty I would've showed her.
I came, I had found out my
mother was dead a few years ago.
I took her some flowers and I
bought her a brick of riches.
Cause that's what she drank.
And when they get down to
suburbs it's, as you know, I see
I see my mother because she usually go
to the go club, early in the
morning, she's an alcoholic.
You know what I'm saying?
Hands are swollen and stuff.
And she always be at the
go club early morning.
She wasn't there.
I stayed there all day.
And then I seen the lady in the store,
that work in the go club.
I say, "You seen my mama?"
She said, "You don't know?
Your mama passed away."
And (sniffles)
Which I never got a chance to say goodbye.
- [Interviewer] So you
cut yourself sometimes?
- I hurt myself because I
don't want to hurt my family.
I don't wanna hurt no one.
My mother, anybody in my family,
they might say bad things to me
but I've never put my hands
on no one or my family.
Cause last time I did, I
hurt my baby sister too.
I pushed her through a hole in the floor
and she said something about my dad
and didn't even know him.
But she still said she
wished my daddy is dead
or something like that.
And I pushed her.
We was playing in an abandoned building
we shouldn't have been playing anyway
And she, I covered the
hole up and she walked
over to the hole, it's like
a straight drop to the floor.
But after then I never hurt no one.
Not my sister or no one in my family.
- [Interviewer] The cutting
started for you when?
- It started when no one would see me.
- [Interviewer] When you were young, or?
It started when I was like
14, 13 years old, 12 years old
people used to say, I'm
trying to commit suicide.
I'm not trying to commit suicide.
It's just me releasing pressure.
If I was trying to kill myself
I know how to cut the vein straight up.
This is my way of just-
when I get angry, I don't hurt nobody.
I'd rather hurt myself than anyone.
And I'm not trying to kill myself.
Cause I was trying to kill myself
like years ago, I would have,
I took pills, overdoses
and no one really cared.
My mom'd go, "Oh, you going
to another psych ward"
But every time she say something abusive
to me or that she didn't, that
I've done something wrong.
And I still try to please her
and she's still do it, you know?
And so,
but my mother and the only
and then shoot up too, I
used to shoot up a lot.
I just shoot up, it called speedball.
I did some speedball with my uncle.
And that's when the Hep
C came out, you know.
I ain't know nothing
about it, ain't no, he
I was too young. My uncle
was older, you know?
And through needle, that
was my stupid mistake
but that my uncle used to shoot it for me.
You know, I've never told my mother
and nobody in the family.
Cause I asked her, I wanted to
know how you do it, you know?
And as shoot up the,
but I'm being laid on.
When I chosen this religion
it was just strictly to keep me in line.
But something happened
at the mosque where one
of the guys asked me for sex
and I figured that was wrong.
And I said brothers don't
ask, you don't do that.
And when you asked me I
figured it was a set up.
But when I finally did, I
just pretty much my faith
was dwindled about going to
the mosque theater, whatnot, you know?
So I have to leave it alone.
I go to a mosque theater with,
with transgenders and lesbians
made for for LGBT community
in Chicago, you know?
And it's that's the only
place that I belong.
I don't go around here no more
because someone put my name out there.
I guess it's a good thing.
They stopped me from going there.
I wouldn't go now anyway
it, cause I be reading
the crime and people,
they said, "Why would you
deny someone worship?"
They denied me worship.
And they say, God is
deserving of our worship.
Then if God's deserving of our worship
why can't I worship him too?
- [Interviewer] Do you have any friends?
- Yeah. This girl named Paula.
I call her my friend, yes
She's got the dog named Ariel.
And ah,
the dog just takes advantage of me.
She comes, she just jumped
up on me and lick me.
And tries to lick me in my mouth when I
she just takes advantage, trust me,
she be humpin and everything, you know?
And that's pretty much it.
I had just, this other person
I thought was my friend.
He wasn't my friend.
I was about to get into a fight
well, I didn't get into a fight.
I could have fought back, but
I wanted to see the reaction
of the person that his name was Black.
And I said, I came around them, right.
And I couldn't whoop the dude
but what's the name I wanted
to see if they was going
to either help, try to
help me and say anything.
They didn't say anything.
They turned their back.
So I let him, when he hit me,
I just got up and walked away.
And usually out of the fight
I don't give a damn about fighting
but I walked away cause
they showed me right there
that they were, he wasn't my friend.
They wasn't my friend.
They didn't even say nothing,
they turned they face.
That's why I walked away.
- [Interviewer] All right. Thank you.
Thank you so much for talking to me.
- No problem.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with everything.
- Well, I'm tryin to get into-
I might even try to-
Probably going to try to
go to rehab, maybe (laughs)
after I gets some cigarettes,
but I gotta go to rehab.
I don't know what else to do.
Just make my life better.
You know,
I don't know how to live and
if I could find the right guidance.
I'm already lost.
And I believe I have angels that talk
and people see me talking
as I talk to angels.
Yes. Yeah.
They're my friends and
they listened to me.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Well thank you for talking to me.
- Alright, well I'm gonna put these back.